guten morgen liebe kollegen gelegen
nehmen sie platz
die sitzung eröffnet bevor wir in die
tagesordnung eintreten müssen wir einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag behandeln
die fraktion der afg hat fristgerecht
beantragt die heutige tagesordnung zu
erweitern und zwar um ihren antrag auf
drucksache 13 76 zu dem vorschlag für
eine verordnung des europäischen
parlaments und des rates zur festsetzung
von emissionsnormen für neue
personenkraftwagen und vielleicht für
neue leichte nutzfahrzeuge im rahmen des
gesamtkonzepts der union zur
verringerung der co2 emissionen von
personenkraftwagen und leichten
nutzfahrzeugen und auch änderungen der
verordnung nur auf 17 79 15 2007
es handelt sich um eine
subsidiaritätsrüge die fraktion der
stadt beantragt diesen anlagen anstoß
sein die geschäftsbereiche ihnen bau und
heimat ohne aussprache abzustimmen wird
das wort zur geschäftsordnung gewünscht
das wort hat der abgeordnete patrick
spaniel
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrte damen und herren letzte
woche wurde eine eu verordnung auf die
tagesordnung der ausschüsse gesetzt
diese eu verordnung tritt in kraft wenn
dieses parlament kein widerspruch hierzu
einlegt die frist für den widerspruch
ist der 27 heute verläuft die ab die eu
verordnung betrifft die festlegung von
emissionsarmen für personenkraftwagen
die begleit unterlagen zu diesem
dokument umfassen viele hundert seiten
die frist der vorbereitung hätte eine
woche betragen
nun weiß ich ja dass in diesem parlament
wenige ingenieure sitzen
gibt es jemanden der schon mal der
entwicklung des fahrzeugs im
antriebsbereich gearbeitet hast dann bin
ich wieder einziehen ich habe die
unterlagen zu dieser emission verordnung
gelesen um wie ich denke auch verstanden
ich kann mir beim besten willen nicht
vorstellen dass viele leute hier in
diesem parlament wenn überhaupt jemand
einen vergleichbaren wissenstand dazu
hat ich halte es deshalb für wichtig
dass wir diese eu-verordnung diskutieren
mindestens aber eine subsidiaritätsrüge
aussprechen und zwar vor ablauf der
subsidiarität bist und das bedeutet ganz
praktisch hier und heute
ich denke wir sind es ich denke wir sind
es den menschen in diesem land schuldig
dass wir uns mit dieser verordnung
beschäftigen
und wenn die autoindustrie in
deutschland derart massiv bedroht wird
sollten wir uns damit befassen
zumindest die menschen in meinem
wahlkreis in stuttgart ist das sehr viel
wichtiger als die anerkennung der
rohingya in miramar was unser nächster
punkt auf der tagesordnung wäre grob
gesagt geht es in der verordnung darum
realitätsnahe verbrauchs test für pkw
und leichte nutzfahrzeuge einzuführen
die grenzwerte sind dabei so gewählt
dass wir für pkw mit benzinmotoren eine
verbrauchs obergrenze von 4 liter haben
dies mag unter laborbedingungen und von
kleinwagen erfüllbar seien
aber meiner einschätzung nach ist dies
bereits von mittelklasse limousinen und
der realen test bedingungen nicht
erfüllt als konsequenz müssten wir den
verbrennungsmotor oberhalb des
kleinwagen segment durch elektroantriebe
ersetzen
ich kann mir nicht erklären warum dieses
wichtige thema was praktisch durch ein
eu gesetz das ende des
verbrennungsmotors verordnet von ihnen
nicht erkannt wurde und hier und hier in
diesem parlament ohne jede debatte ohne
jede debatte oder abstimmung akzeptiert
wird
diese eu regelung trifft das herzstück
unserer wirtschaft hier in deutschland
genau genommen ist diese offene
aggressivität der eu gegen die deutsche
autoindustrie und letztlich gegen die
arbeitnehmer in unserem land ein skandal
ein noch größerer skandal wäre es wenn
dieses deutsche parlament dieser
regelung ohne jede debatte zustimmt
genau das wollen wir verhindern
wir wollen in diesem parlament eine
sachliche konstruktive debatte über
dieses thema führen die menschen in
dieser industrie sind es die im
wesentlichen dieses land am laufen
halten und ihre soziale umverteilungs
fantasien überhaupt finanzieren und auch
ihre persönliche existenz hier
finanzieren
und diese menschen diese menschen haben
ein recht darauf dass wir uns mit ihren
interessen beschäftigen
herr kollege spaniel darf ich sie darauf
hinweisen dass sie zur gründung eines
geschäfts und entsprechend die
potenzierung zur sache die potenzielle
vernichtung hunderttausende
arbeitsplätze in deutschland
sollte uns mindestens genauso wichtig
sein wie ein menschenrechts thema in mia
ich danke ihnen ich habe meine damen und
herren das war der afg abgeordnete der
spaniel hier in einem
geschäftsordnungsantrag der der
regulären debatte vorgezogen ist er
möchte gerne für seine fraktion das 1
das diskutiert wird eine verordnung zur
festsetzung von kfz emission dass der
hier im bundestag diskutiert wird
also herr kollege spaniens muss mich
schon sehr stefan müller
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
unionsfraktion ist der nächste redner in
dieser debatte
bei diesem tagesordnungspunkt gar nicht
das wort ergriffen hat
und dann
und dann stellen sie sich hin und sagen
der bundestag würde das ohne debatte
durch winken ja antrag auf aussetzung
heute hätte ja auch ohne debatte laufen
sollen so was doch von ihnen beantragt
das ist doch unglaubwürdig kurz
vorzuwerfen dass sie ohne die partie
wollen wenn sie selber habe ich anders
haben wollen
nun nehme kolleginnen und kollegen die
afg beantragt also jetzt kurzfristig
dieses thema auf die tagesordnung zu
setzen und bin und sagt dann dass das ja
auch betont dies sei besonders dringlich
dass wir uns mit diesem punkt heute hier
befassen nun besonders dringlich richtig
ist dass die frist für die erteilung
oder das aussprechen einer
subsidiaritätsrüge am dienstag ab läuft
ja richtig ist auch es ist heute der
letzte sitzungstag um darüber zu
debattieren nur liebe kolleginnen
kollegen das scheint den kollegen von
kolleginnen von der afd
erst gestern abend aufgefallen zu sein
weil nämlich der antrag auf aussetzung
gestern abend um 17 uhr 54 beim
parlament sekretär hat überhaupt erst
eingegangen ist
reise zu einem zeitpunkt
liebe kollegen zu einem zeitpunkt wo wir
hier schon mit wahlen und abstimmungen
beschäftigt waren wo also noch nicht
einmal mehr die möglichkeit für alle
anderen fraktionen gewesen wäre sich
sorgfältig mit diesem antrag
auseinanderzusetzen
eine sinnvolle beratung jedenfalls war
so nicht mehr möglich und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der afd
sie hätten ja zeit genug gehabt
der verordnungsentwurf ist am 18
november 2017 von der eu kommission
vorgelegt worden sie hätten mehr als
vier monate zeit gehabt einen
ordentlichen antrag hier einzureichen
damit sich der bundestag auf damit
ordentlich hätte beschäftigen können
wir hatten alleine in diesem jahr sechs
sitzungswochen wo wir das hätten tun
können wenn sie einen antrag eingebracht
hätten und weiß ich ja nichts
nun weiß ich ja nicht was bei ihnen
schief gelaufen ist aber vier monate
passiert nichts bei einem thema das
offensichtlich ihnen sehr sehr wichtiges
dann kommen sie auf den letzten drücker
ohne dass alle anderen fraktionen
gelegenheit haben sich damit einmal
auseinander zu setzen da machen wir
nicht mit liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
mal ganz davon abgesehen
mal ganz davon abgesehen dass sie es ja
noch nicht einmal nötig hatten uns vorab
darüber zu informieren dass die planen
einen solchen antrag einzureichen und
gelegenheit dazu hätten sie ja gehabt
also letzte woche letzte woche
letzte woche in mit druck waren wir in
einer interfraktionellen runde
zusammengesessen und haben über die
tagesordnung dieser woche beraten
kein wort von der afg einem solchen
antrag einbringen
letzte woche donnerstag haben wir im
ältestenrat die tagesordnung für diese
sitzungswoche beschlossen kein wort der
afg einem solchen antrag einzureichen
diese woche dienstag waren wir in einer
runde der parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer zusammengesessen kein
wort der afg zu diesen antrag am mikro
eine runde von fraktionsmitarbeitern
zusammen kein wort von der afg zu diesem
antrag und gestern nachmittag am
donnerstagnachmittag waren wir im
ältestenrat sie werden schon wissen kein
wort der afd
zu diesem antrag zwei stunden bevor sie
den antrag eingerichtet haben oder
antrag eingereicht haben waren wir noch
zusammen und sie haben es nicht für
nötig gehalten darüber uns zu
informieren das ist schlechter stil auch
gegenüber allen anderen fraktionen in
denen wir kolleginnen
herr kollegin müller auch bei geschäften
unsere platten gibt es eine begrenzung
wir reden zu haben sie haben vier monate
nicht gemacht sie haben vier monate
geschlafen kommen auf dem letzten
drücker ohne dass wir eine gelegenheit
hatten dazu uns damit zu beschäftigen
wir lehnen den antrag auf aussetzung ab
die ablehnung der unionsfraktion stefan
müller warf der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der cdu csu er gehört
der csu an und hat hier während einer
rede applaus aus dem gesamten haus außer
natürlich der afg fraktion bekommen dr
wenn wenig gemaßregelt hat es gibt jetzt
keine weitere geschäftsordnungsdebatte
weil andere parlamentarische
geschäftsführer sich nicht zu wort
gemeldet haben jetzt die abstimmung die
afd
also für die aussetzung des antrages den
sie hier vorgelegt hat und der rest des
hauses alle anderen fraktionen dagegen
es geht um das noch mal in erinnerung zu
bringen um vorschläge der eu zur senkung
der co2 emissionen der europaweit die
nach meinung der afg unverhältnismäßig
auf die belastung der deutschen
automobilindustrie zählen ziele mit
fraktion gegen ist im dfb abgelehnt
[Applaus]